uh my name is Mike Miller and I will be
a tutorial instructor for the next 90
minutes I would like to introduce myself
in a few seconds so I've been a
dedicated python user since 1999 so I
can always claim since the last
Millennium starting with version 1.52 we
just discussed this here uh so I do have
a scientific background wrote we worked
at a research institute and then a 2004
gave my first training and built the
things developed and since 2010 I spent
most of my time on python training so I
do quite a bit of these kind of things
that I'm doing here
good uh today we want to talk about
aspected on the programming I just would
like to know a little bit about you very
quickly
um
who uses python less than one year
please raise your hand
good between one and three years
a few people between three and five
okay most more than five
yeah so kind of equal more or less equal
distribution so the time of using python
is not the best uh measure to how good
you are in person what you know but
you're here to launch something you know
about some features of python so please
download the material I upload the the
QR code was wrong
um miss my tool to create our codes was
in there so that Trump has somehow
copied the name twice so but now this is
a this is a code it will be the it's a
PDF and the source code so please use
this bitly link there attracted there
should work
um especially on the programming
give you a little bit time and then I
would go quickly to the material you
want to cover since we have only one
session which is not much
so and uh
I'm gonna use a Jupiter lab notebook you
don't have to you can use whatever tool
you like
you're encouraged to work along if you
like to if you don't like you just want
to watch this also fine I try not to be
too fast even though we don't have much
time so I have to speed up the things
first I would everybody has the link so
add
quickly go through this is the material
that so if you download you will have
this PDF with the material
and this is
the content so I make it a bit bigger
here so we're gonna have there's two big
sections basic decorators where explain
the basics that you get to know how to
write your own decorations and then we
go in with a few more advanced topics
like parameterization and using classes
writing decorators and all kind of
things you can do with decorators yeah
so I do have examples for all of them
and also we do have exercises but due to
the kind of short time we can already we
cannot do the exercises doesn't work so
you have to get the exercise as a
homework I do have a solution
PDF so I will add the solution PDF after
the training does the same link to the
same zip file if you download it and
then you will have Solutions which are
example Solutions yeah so it's a it's
quite a bit of topic that's why that's
why we have to stop them
skip the
exercises doing yourself so I do start
with this um
with a notebook
I always make a notebook and the first
one is the basics
Basics basic decorators and we look at
what decorators are what they're good
for so who of you use decorators who put
this at sign in your code and it does
something who've used it
mostly people
who wrote or tried to write our own
decorator
quite a few people so so first I want to
give you some
incentive why we do need decorators so I
mentioned I started with python 15 and I
think in one five you could do very
similar things then you can do this
decorators which are a bit newer so
motivation
um
the motivation for decorator so if you
have a class
with lowercase class so by the way is
this uh big enough font for the back of
the room
yeah okay so if you have a class and I I
do find the class then I can have
something like a static method so in
Python static methods are not really
necessary if you don't want to so yeah I
think you could delete static method
from language and still would work a
language like Java you need to write
functions so a static method is
uh just a
a function that resides inside the class
so this wouldn't work because I forgot
the self but I don't want the self and
to do this I can
do something like this I can say a
static method and torrent is function in
the aesthetic method which does nothing
it circumvents a binding so usually when
you have a method in the class then you
can call it through instance and you
don't use yourself but you have to put
yourself in here so this is this class
on I can use this function
this function on the class and
it behaves like this and I can do the
same thing for
um
the instance I have to make first so I
have to make instance first not using
the instance so I make instance of my
class and this works so this does the
same if I if I don't have
the static method if I have a method and
the method I would write a self in here
and then I do the same thing I return
the remote attendees would like you to
show the QR code longer so they can also
download the material and stuff
yeah so
um
this would be the link
um decorators
QR code
is program
that's a new art code
that's a new one please cannot try it
but it should be like that because I saw
the mistake when I made here's the new
one
so I delete it over
uh
decorators are a great means of
injecting so the motivation before they
go to the basics are great needs to
inject code that's why it's called
expect oriented you have an aspect some
kind of what's called cross-cutting
concern
and we come through some examples like
logging or caching and decorators are
great means to inject this code into
your program
yeah and this is typically called a
spectranded programming to give it a
fancy a fancy name
we can also say decorators are functions
that take functions return functions so
that's doesn't sound much better but
that's essentially what happens good so
everybody has a link so continue so now
we have this uh this class let's see the
the normal is so now if I go to the and
I have my my instance maybe that's not
good flow if I have this normal instance
on my C I can call my method yeah and
when I
I have to redefine everything so if I
call My Method I this works if I do the
same thing on the class it doesn't work
because it's bound and if I call it like
this I get an error message and I have
to supply the first argument that's
objective programming you need the self
argument you have to write yourself so
sometimes you want to have a static
method which is just a function that's
located inside the class
let's look at inside the class
and just a normal function but for
organizational reasons you want to have
it in the class so you see it's very
important that you know that's a static
method person think behaves differently
so I didn't forget the self I don't want
to write the self but this only becomes
clear if I see this line the problem is
I can only write this line after the
fact I have to define the function first
before I can write list line
yeah and that's a kind of a problem here
it's kind of a k because the function is
very short
if this function has 10 20 lines you
might not see this line there I'm just
wondering what it is
yeah this can be problematic so and now
there's something new instead of this we
use
a decorator so I call this class C2 and
now I do the same thing I achieve the
same thing by adding a decorator here
and I use static method in front which
does exactly the same though this would
be equivalent to this line so if I can
delete this line and now if I do this
this would behave exactly the same and
if I make a new instance of my cost then
my
uh function
malfunction would run
on the class without a problem yeah so
that's the whole thing that's that's
that's what it's doing so this static
method decorator
uh
it's just doing this line for you
very important thing is that is you do
it in front you can see it and it's also
a nice colorful magenta of color here
and you see something is happening
something's different and this is an
important thing this is some people call
it syntactic Sugar but it's important
syntactic sugar because this is a very
important message that we convey with
this with these things
good same thing applies to class methods
I'm going to skip this here this is
exactly the same class methods are very
often used in Python to have a kind of
What's called the second Constructor if
you want to call it so crafts methods
are would be another application where
we typically use
uh decorators
where you can find decorators in a while
there are a lot of libraries that use
decorators sometimes extensively click
is one to command line tool program
which is pretty common click Django is
using decorators a lot like for who's
allowed permissions and so on flask is
usually you can decorate or science
student decorators for types number if
anybody's in numerical programming
there's a lot of libraries that use
decorators and they are all for the same
purpose to modify functions in one way
or the other okay this is a motivation
and
the important thing is that you think
this one is just exactly the same as
this line and when you know this you can
explain a lot of things what actually
happens with stack writers otherwise
there's a too much magic but in the end
it's just this thing that's that's going
to happen
and if you do this you can explain to
yourself what what happens
I would like to introduce a novel
um
concept the concept of a closure who
knows what the closure is
yeah a few people so closure is a term
from functional programming and since we
have a function it takes a function
returns a function this is some some
kind of stuff from functional
programming so python is a
multi-paradigm programming language and
it supports a few functional features
it's not a real pure functional language
but it has a functional features and I
give you an example I have this uh
out of function inside a function I can
define a new function so I can define a
new function which I call enorm which
takes an argument too and now I can say
return argument one plus argument two
and now I do do this a different
a different thing I say return
uh
return this you know function so I
generate a new function and now I can
say nl10 is outro
now I can have this thing which is a
function and I can call it with four and
you see you get a 14. so this is
actually calling the thing
so I generate a new function if you look
at the function you see this function
this is a function with a strange name
with a strange name and the outer
function does nothing else then give me
back an inner function
and of course I Supply the four here but
somehow it remembers a 10. yeah usually
when you have a function you get
something in when the function is gone
everything is gone all those variables
inside a function are are not available
anymore yeah there's scoping there's a
local scope of the function when you
call it the available if the function is
called that one but somehow this inner
function has access to this Arc one from
the outer function and how does it work
how does it work so and this works with
this closure so you can say closure only
see if you look at the closure this is a
tuple which you can see by this trailing
comma here a one tube has a comma there
you can access
the first element and then you can
look at the cell content and there you
have your 10. so this is a very common
Concept in functional programming and
python uses this also so this Auto
function
holds on these arguments because inner
function needs it so the minute you
define it it'll realize okay this arc2
from this Arc one from outside is used
in here this concept is used now for our
purposes writing a decorator so now we
know about decorators are good for now
we'll know a little bit about closures
how closures work and now we're going to
write our own
simple decorator
so I start with a decorator
that
doesn't really it doesn't really work
but it gives you sometimes it makes
sense to do something that doesn't work
and start to improve uh to make it work
so I write a function hello that takes a
function and prints hello
so this is just a function and now I can
Define I can use my decorator uh hello
and I can Define another function so we
will use always a very simple function
at A and B so we will Define this
function a lot today
I now return a plus b so if you see this
now something strange happens something
strange happens when I apply this
function you see the hello and I Define
this function though something happens
when I Define the function why is this
so the explanation is as follows because
this is just doing the following so this
is always explanation you say add equals
uh hello ad so that's what this
decorator is doing and now it becomes
very clear that you just print add
that works that works The Decorator does
not there's no error message it works
but when I want to call my function
which should give me seven I get this uh
the most
um
common error matches on stack Overflow
none type object doesn't do this and
this and now you have this you have this
program yeah that the non-type is not
callable because I forgot something very
important I'll replace my function with
what with a return value of hello what's
the return value offered hello
it's none if you don't put a return
python automatically returns none so now
replace my function is not
this is probably not what you want
that's I think in all cases a mistake
I'm pretty sure you can do it but it
doesn't make a lot of sense so we have
to write a better
decorator and they do this we have to do
something so you see also this happens
at definition time this could be use
case for decorators to do something at
the ignition time the more common cases
do something at runtimes you'll replace
your function that your function is
doing something different at the runtime
yeah all use cases if I show you one at
least where you can do something at
definition time two different use cases
but most of the time it's runtime so now
I redefined my hello in a more sensible
way so I have a function
and then inside my function I have this
function you can call whatever you like
here I call it repo or whatever you want
and then I use this syntax
who is familiar with the syntax and
knows what it means
uh half the people so I will explain the
syntax in a second because this is
essential
um
and now I do my
this is my aspect to the print hello
here in this case it's the aspect this
is something I always want to add to
functions print hello
that's a double thank you thank you
that's a typo yeah typing and talking
and then I return my function and I use
the same syntax
one aux and W chaos so kwr stands for
keyboard ox and Ox stands for positional
arcs
and then I return my
uh my wrapper
and now I can do the same thing I just
can use this
hello and apply the hello to my
function a and b i defined here
so and see now nothing happens at
definition time but when I
add my numbers I get my result and in
addition I get my
task that is aspect this in this case
printing hello you can do something more
sensible but this shows the concept what
you can do
and now if you look at the function add
it also has a different name this is not
nice we will see later how to improve
this but now add is a different function
because
this one here remember this is just
exactly like here this is just this this
happens so if you look at this side this
happens then you always understand
what's going on okay now uh
what's what's up is this arcs and
keyboard Ox so you need to understand
this concept
to make sense actually otherwise you can
always use as a recipe but it's a good
thing to understand what arcs and
keyboard arcs are so you can Define any
kind of function and you can use arcs
and I just say print aux and you see
when I call this function I can call
this function without any arguments and
I do get an empty Tuple they call this
function with one argument
I get one
two purpose one if I call it this two I
get two plus two and so on so this
star arcs is
collecting all positional arguments so
this function takes an unspecified
number of precision arguments 0 to n
this is a very versatile function
already and this is the first one the
second star uh with a double star
is for keyboard aux and now it's a bit
different so if I call this function
again then you see now I do get an empty
dictionary and if I call this with an
keyword argument I get an empty
dictionary with one element and if I
have these two keyword arguments it's
two and so on yeah something like this
of course you very often you combine it
with that
yeah okay
okay so uh
this is a
the one that catches all positional
arguments
and this is the one that catches or
keyword arguments and the position
arguments will be packaged into a tuple
because the tube will preserves the
procession is a sequence
and the keyword arguments go into a
dictionary nowadays dictionaries also
preserve the sequence because they have
their orders in python36 but
beforehandle was not the case yeah so in
general dictionaries use a hash table
they don't necessarily have order that
they have order now something particular
in Python but still very often the order
is not considered
so now we can combine both yeah so now I
just put those together and then uh you
might guess if if I do this then I can
put them together KW ox and now if I
call my function without anything I do
get two empty structures and if I call
it this
positional and
keyword arguments in any kind of
combination yeah so
the convention you don't put the space
when you quote like this between the
equal sign
under and the value
then you get these ones so this function
can be called as any kind of signature
so any kind of combination of positional
and keyword arguments and this is
important because it's like a joke or
this function can replace any other
function terms of signature so it can
replace any other function if it does
something sensible
I don't know but you can replace it and
this is pretty powerful and there's not
much new because you know how to work
with tuples you know how the rock was
dictionaries is this important it is
often passed in case you always come
back there's the same data structures
you don't have to learn yet another
specialized data structures for
something structure you can use in all
data structure a tube or list or a
dictionary and this is very worthwhile
to to learn all the methods of these
data structures so
and the other way you can also use a
tuple to call
a function let's make a list
yeah so now I can say list a print list
and if I print this list it prints the
list like this but I could write print
list square brackets zero comma is
square brackets one comma list square
brackets to and so on so this would
print it out but
lazy program is a good programmers don't
type the match you could also say
do this unpacking for me the star
unpacks
yeah this star and packs and here it
unpacks this list and it doesn't matter
if the list has three element out of 30
or 300 it will feed them as single
arguments to your print function that
would be useful and this always works
and that's these are the two concepts we
use here to write our wrapper you see
here that's a definition line here we
use
packing so we pack all the arguments in
containers and here we do unpacking we
unpack all the arguments because here's
if you call the function
exactly the same syntax different
context exactly opposite meaning
it's like a light switch if you have if
the light is on you turn it off the
other way each TV works like this and
two year olds can figure this out that's
not that difficult
that's behind here yeah so uh
same syntax different meaning and it's
just a container concept you can also
say the postal concept you send just the
package and the postal office doesn't
care what I put inside the package as
long as it's not the bigger the heavier
and I pay my postage they will
transported for me exactly the same
happens here Post package or container
and container same thing you just ship a
container and you can put anything
inside as long as it's not something
illegal you can put anything inside
again you can shape it yeah that's
that's totally fine and the container
doesn't care and this is a concept we
use here good if you understand this all
the Restless details yeah but let's look
at the details so a few things about
best practices so what we did so far if
I write
a function
at so I'm I don't need to copy I don't
need to type this I have my function
here and I forgot the most important
thing in my function what's the most
important thing in a function
the dog string exactly good the dark
string I forgot a dog string so you can
use single or double uh double triple
quoted I'm Pi convention use double for
normal strings that you're single other
people might have different but I think
it doesn't really matter too much
add two objects so this is the most
important thing
so now if I have this one I do have a
dog string which you can access via this
dock attribute or a lot of other tools
like in my notebook the question mark
will X do exactly this access to talk
attribute and shows me the docs ring
here nicely
so this is very important
and the other thing would be the name so
if you look at the name of the function
then you would get the
uh the name like this yeah so each
function has Stringer name you can
change this name
this is
you might call a meta programmer already
so if you do meta program you have to
know what you're doing it's very
powerful but it can also can be pretty
dangerous so if you change your name in
the function if you want to or not it
depends on you so if you take the same
it takes the same decorator and the same
function decorate it with my hello
yeah I put my hello in front
and now
if I look at my function and I look at
the doc string
then I see
my doc string is gone and if I look at
the name
if I look at the name
look at the name then it's called report
because by it's called rapper because
this is
the name of this function I used here
which is not good because now the whole
thing about decorators is to reuse a
decorator so if I use this decorator a
50 times in my code I have 50 functions
called wrapper
yeah that's not nice for debuggings you
don't want this one so that's why best
practices is to
use a decorator so from
from
Funk tools
from Funk tools yeah Funk tools is a
functional features so I thought it's a
function programming import reps so
we're not launched that there's not
nothing to eat but it's a decorator so
you put the decorator here and you say
wraps and you have to tell what it wraps
so it's kind of redundant but you have
to say you wrap this function and this
if you look at reps it does nothing much
just replacing a few attributes like the
doctor in the name and a few others it
just goes to the original function and
copies from there to the wrapper so the
wrapper is still a new object with a
different IDE but all the attributes it
looks good enough that you think it's
original function so if your user is
test with the ID you will get a
different thing because it produces a
new object but
all the attributes
will be now much nicer so if I do the
same thing again
so I can do this again so you have to
run the notebook in sequence otherwise
you have to give new names for the
functions now if I look at a function
doc string then you see
it's still there still there yeah and
also the name should be much nicer
let's add
so you can look at the code it's not
very difficult you call the other
function this one goes through all the
attributes and there's a list of
attributes which might change a little
bit if you use a different python
function so if a new python version gets
a new attribute to functions then they
might add it to the list so if you use
this one you don't have it you don't
have to do it by hand because for the
right python version they have the right
list of attributes you need to add yeah
this can be a bit tricky if you do this
inside in a class with nested methods
also it might be strange because it has
a it looks for a module and some
functions that are generally dynamically
don't have a module attribute and then
you get the error message in the module
then you would need to write if you look
at that this reps calls other functions
where you can specify the list then you
could modify the list if you really
wanted to it's possible good that's best
practice always use a decorator
and do this recursion when you use
recursion then you have to be careful
once you decorate a function to function
will call the decorated function or the
original function then you might have
some
if you actually execute your aspect in
every recursion but recursion is
something you should try to avoid in
Python if it's possible it's not very
performant so then you can do iteration
obviously iteration and use recursion
only when you have
the problem that relents itself the
recursive processing like nested nodes
or something that could be something
otherwise recursion is not the best
thing to do in Python
good this uh this is the basics of
decorators let's look at a few use cases
so to give you a feeling what what you
can do so I have a few use cases when
you unpacked the
um
the source code you should see some of
these python files so there's a bunch of
other stuff in here some python files
and I just load them here and I load
this cached yeah load this caching thing
cached I call caching cached and this is
a very very simple cache so don't use it
in production this is just a proof of
concept how to make a cache and they use
a decorator
so I use pickle here to generate a key
so the pickle multiple person that might
work for you or might not work for you
and you see now we have the same thing
we have we have this um
this decorator this is Def so this is a
scaffolding obviously if you have two
deaths you have to have two returns very
easy later on we see kind of has three
deaths nested but these stick with two
so I put the cache in the outer function
this might not but might not be the best
architectural decision to do it because
you cannot reach it easily from there
but for this purpose it should be fine
so a dictionary typically is the first
thing you go with is a cache and you
could also easily make a persistent
dictionary with child for something like
this and then we have our uh aux keyword
arcs and here you see a pattern very
often you call this cached and the
nested one down for underscore cached
underscore cached just because this name
will be the disappear anyway it's just a
temporary name so this big body have to
give the name then you use underscore
that's pretty common and you see this
dumps is just pickle this creates a tube
with all arcs and keyboards so Tuple of
um
the arguments and the Tuple of the
keywords
and
of course now the objects have to be
applicable so if you hand something in
there's no pickle that's not going to
work yeah so and then I just say okay if
the key is not the cache yet then I do
call the function at producer result and
put it into the cache dictionary
otherwise you'll just return it so
caching is usually only useful if this
function is expensive so for our example
what we're using now so if I execute
this and I put my
um my decorator cached
in front of our add function
yeah for this function caching wouldn't
be wouldn't be useful because the a plus
b if it's numbers if it's not something
very big you never know so plus can do
anything but if just numbers this would
be much faster than do this caching
thing and now I need to add something
here to to make this visible
yeah and I'm at adding now if I add my
I think now you see
um
it calls
the function shows adding now it returns
to nine and doesn't call adding now it
shortcuts
it it just takes a result from the
dictionary and doesn't call the function
that's the principle of caching
and there's a decorator you have a kind
of elegant way to turn a normal function
into a cached function
turn a normal function into a cached
function
so that's possible to do and you could
also very often you apply this decorator
with this syntax but you could also use
the other syntax when you as we used up
here this our syntax thing so sometimes
you want to keep the old function around
and make a new function and use just use
a different name here and then you can
do it also that can be useful it's also
use case
the the original function by the way is
is available so add has an attribute
called uh wrapped and this points to the
original function that is not cached
so it's always there you can use it so
these sample things are typically
internal names of python you have to
know what they mean don't invent them
yourself read up what they mean and use
them accordingly defining them you have
to read the documentation otherwise your
object might behave maybe not the way
you intended yep so otherwise they are
useful for reading when you modify them
you have to really think maybe it does a
better way of doing it
sometimes it can be be useful so when
you do debugging you can do anything
with your program yeah and you can do
all kinds of nasty things because the
historical the way and you've done this
debugging when you write something
that's still a little bit longer than a
few hours then
don't do it that was a question
yeah the cache is stored in the
functions in the closure that's a good
question so if you look at this cache
thing then you look at this uh
at the ad they should have this closure
if I'm not mistaken so see if we have it
until you have two closer cells and you
can look at at the cells
and the first one is the cell content
and this is my cache yeah this is a
dictionary and this the thing is there's
a b there's a bytes is a pickle thing so
it's it's now I use a closure and stored
in the function this is not you can
still access it but maybe it's not the
best way yeah but just to know the
dictionary an addiction I was modified
but I could say uh this give it the name
cash now I'll say clear and then remove
everything from a dictionary
decorated with its own
its own cache yeah because you you make
you make a new closure
yeah sure
that's one way of doing it it's just an
example in the real world you might want
to have this cache as a global variable
or use something else to put the cache
somewhere else make an argument so you
can also then basically we can use a
parameterized stacker writer and you can
even hand in an existing dictionary as a
cache if you want
it would be possible yeah that's just
the principle that you can do something
with this
business cashier
good so this would be one use case and
caching is
a prominent cross-cutting concern
because caching usually has nothing to
do with your domain logic you can use
caching for all kinds of problems
and that's typically what this aspecting
is all about all about you have some
tasks that you can need at many
different places and then you have a
decorator and you implement it once they
can use it all over the place
good this would be here the next one is
logging
I have another example so I load my
locked and you see now I have I do
something differently I have a constant
a local a global value which I call the
constant so constant doesn't constants
don't exist in Python but per convention
if you uppercase the whole thing you
call it a constant yeah so now this it's
the same thing so we have two level so
we have use our reps we have our locked
Here and Now
this one inspects the logging if logging
is set it does logging so in this case
my login just is print it's not really
logging but it's just about the
principle and then the rest we know
already so the only thing different is
here this this logging so if it is false
so now I can do the same thing so
instead of of course I'm too lazy
um
I use this but we don't need a we don't
need the the print here but instead of
cache we say instead of cash we say log
yeah and we lock the thing
huh and I have to execute the cell first
to get it to go
logged okay now I have called my
function and you see
no logging happens because this constant
logging is false now I change the
concept so change the constant to your
runtime is kind of dubious but for
testing you can do it I change the
constant and now if I do this again then
I do get a login so I can turn on and
off my login globally by changing this
value and I don't have to sprinkle a lot
of ifs around my code all the place
because I can only do it in The
Decorator once
that could be useful and sometimes you
want to switch something on and off
um
could change for positive but how much
it locked what log level also can't and
so on all these things you you know this
is just a principle
to give you another example for
cross-cutting concern so you can
probably come up as other cross-calling
concerns for things you might need at
different places
good
this
is the basics
any questions
I don't know is there if the slider
thing do they have slidering here
so if you have any any questions so far
yeah
the cell contents that usually it it's
it's interesting though but it's not
essential to understand decorators
because it's stored there on the name
when you just access it and how it's
done technically it's not that important
I would say it's just in just if you
want to know how it works then it's it's
a closure and inside the closure you
have this content
and uh it's in the in this Tuple and
these the very in the order they're used
they will be stored and then passing
will access them
the details are not important to write
good decorations to this problem and so
is it specific to Jupiter to sell
contents
nothing here specific interpreter I just
use Jupiter as a tool because it's easy
to present step by step everything what
I do here Works in any kind of your Ides
just press play in Python here's nothing
special about Jupiter
and only the the execution is
interesting here yeah another question
no good so this is the basics
um now we know how to write a decorate
another question
yeah this is yeah in general this is a
convention in private but here's just
used because this name it disappears
anyway because this reps makes this
function name disappear anyway because
this one is just the temporary function
that doesn't doesn't serve any purpose
it doesn't want to have an old name
because it's just a Helper and very
often it's a convention use the same
name as outside until the signatures
let's use underscore theoretically you
can use any name that doesn't really
matter because this name doesn't appear
anywhere because you want it to go away
yeah
is nothing special it's not for special
in Python it's just a convention if two
underscores in the class it's different
name angling but with one is just a
convention pretty strong convention so
yeah
good okay Basics yeah
I should should
the original function the new function
will have so because if you have ADD
is at dot this is original function
yeah yeah so there's a way this is
uh no but is is object identity you
cannot you cannot mingle with the S you
could make a visit with this equal site
and I haven't because equal sign you
could do this if this is classes you
could do this instead of function using
instances that are comparable then you
could implement the the LT that under
the EQ is equal and then you can make it
equal so um because if I use it double
equal I'm not even sure if it's
implemented for functions or never
useful courses then you could add this
case your faults but if you really want
it then you can either become it on if
you really want you can make this two
but why I'm not sure another question
yield now yield is difference it was
yield has a generator function and even
it's called the generator function it's
a totally different Beast it's not a
function anymore
as a yield you won't get and deposit
yield is for this iterator protocol and
it's called generator function but you
could just give it maybe a totally
different name generator
whatever and not function because you
use a function syntax but as soon as you
yield this thing behaves totally
differently than the function it
wouldn't work because it has no return
or nothing it's just not gonna
yeah
dollars of functions
um
[Music]
there's metal methods you you could go
into the namespace because you can use
this method so if you want to do it
programmatically then you would use this
syntax
up here which I showed you yeah in our
this syntax if you use this syntax then
you can do it programmatically you only
have to get all your functions somehow
yeah you can the namespace globals
locals of of a module is available it's
a dictionary you can go through and
decorate all of them that would be a bit
meta programming not very difficult you
just have to get all your modules which
you can import
and then you go through the global and
then you figure out who's a function and
maybe figure out by name which functions
you want there will be a lot of
conventions I'm not sure if it's
recommended it's technically possible
I'm not cool if there's a good concept
because it's very indirect you don't see
that they're decorated so maybe explicit
is better the implicit I don't know how
many functions you have if you have 10
maybe just write 10 decorators if have a
few hundred
functions then maybe rethink your
architecture to
have them Addiction in the first place
or something
yeah so it's possible if you want
because you just can use this one you
can always programmatically apply
decorators to functions or replace them
this is a that might be some Corner
cases I've I've done cover here and you
will get some might get some surprises
to do the things you do think yeah
that's what can happen it's just a
question why you want to do it and maybe
there's a better way to achieve what you
want
so I wrote a decorator you can also
decorate
methods of a class and you can write the
class decorator that decorates all the
methods
that's pretty easy to do that's not very
difficult if you want to you can do an
example and that makes maybe more sense
because then you have all this so if you
want this then instead of writing
functions just put all your functions in
the class and then use a class decorator
and then say class decorator give it a
good name and then you can see ah this
all these methods are decorated
automatically somehow
this then you said class decorator take
this decorator then the class decorator
decorates all the methods
I don't know if I could throw this out
in a few minutes but this wouldn't be
that difficult yeah
[Music]
The Decorator
yeah that comes up later the next
parameterized decorations you mean yeah
that's that's the next one so I would
stop now the question cover more we can
do more uh questions later this is the
basics and since we have Basics there's
more advanced usages
and I do make a new notebook if I can
get my mouse I have a control here and
we say um
advanced
so
now I'm skipping the exercises
and you encourage to do the exercises
rode your own decorator and this
exercise is riding a decorator that uses
time it uh default timer which is a
timestamp just measure all the functions
it to the time step before run your
function two times The Plato and get the
difference this pretty cools there are
better methods but for an example it's
good enough then you can put out of
decorate a function you would
automatically get the runtimes of these
functions
you can't get as fancy as you want is
there you can just print it out or you
can store them and if you call function
multiple times what you do with the time
a lot of options there but this would be
the exercise here so in terms of time
constraints uh I do go to the advanced
section so
if you have our hello decorator
and I'm gonna when I write a good buy
decorator that says goodbye so if I have
my nice hello decorator somewhere here
that works this is one without the
wrapper this is a better one
down here
so I have Hello here if I want have one
that says goodbye I copy the whole code
and change the string to goodbye right
yeah so if you copy a whole thing and
change very little that should be a red
light this is obviously not the good way
to do it don't repeat yourself so if you
have this whole thing
um
just replacing this with
goodbye might not be a good solution so
I would make it a more General solution
a solution and just add another level
yeah you can solve any problem with
another level in Direction that's what
we're doing here say now call it say and
I call this text and I put this in so
and I just indent the whole thing and
important you have to match the returns
with definitions and I
export something now I can change the
names so here I use underscore say
yeah and here I change hello into text
so hopefully you'll survive all these
changes text and here I change report to
double underscore so that's yeah and
typically they are not more than two
underscores in Python once we go into
two so that's where we're going to stop
and then I'll say here return double
underscore say and here return
so you see we just add another
level outside otherwise the otherwise is
the same and then how do we get our text
from there to there again it's a closure
now we have a double closure if you want
because we have another nesting level so
and now I can use my decoration and
and I can supply the string I want to
have here as hello I could also say
called creating or whatever you want or
just print out or
doesn't really matter Dev add a and b so
I skipped the dog straight here you know
it has to be there return a plus b
so if I call my function
it does print yeah so now much better
this the functionality is exactly the
same only the data is different the text
now I want to hand in the data so you
have to do this now if you want to write
this one in one line This is not that
easy so doing the same thing
so I Define this function
yeah so now I have this say and this say
returns
back a new function that calls the
functional to say add equals and this
one calls add on it
and I hope this is correct
yeah I have to get rid of this ad sign
so if I do this now
my ad should do the same
that's what it's doing yeah see a bit
tricky because this first consumes
the parameter or the argument in this
case Hello gives me back a new function
on this function I call giving the ad
yeah so if you're a functional
programmer that looks very easy if
you're not so used to a function it
might look a bit scary here yeah but
that's what happens
um
in the background
um and we can do something like this
so
this would be a parameterization
and that's used a lot see if you use a
tool like click then you always put some
kind of parameters in there okay this is
a command line command and then you say
okay what types or whatever you we put
in there if you use science and you
specify the data types yeah and seism is
something you can compile python to see
and it's useful to specify C data types
to make it faster that's the whole
purpose of the thing
now if I have this we are not not
restricted to one decorator
you can always apply as many decorators
as you like therefore when you write a
decorator you should never assume you're
the only
uh decorator
yeah and you see now if I call my
function
then
it says hello goodbye so you can put as
many as you like no restriction
you have to be careful those static
method and cross method I think they
always have to be the innermost
decorator there are some some of the
build elements that are a bit tricky and
if you put them in the wrong place you
get the Strange error message so you
have to read up on the documentation
because these are Implement they do
something special yeah so they they
violate the concept that they shouldn't
battle that order use and decorator but
when you write your own you better write
it in a way it doesn't matter if it's
called the first or the last
good so you might have seen some web
developments where they have a lot of
decorators a big stack of decorators
yeah and then if we have more yeah then
it should be called the general because
it's highly decorated that's really what
they do with this that's not that's not
my joke I got it from the web guys yeah
there it is yeah
good this is decoration and this
improves a lot when you get away with
other environment or do it if you don't
uh
then you have to use a thing so now we
have this three level thing
and if you use a tool like McCabe also
and and it analyze the code for
complexity every level of indentation or
nesting gives increases your complexity
according to this tool yeah so but they
can kind of reduce it a little bit
because now I would introduce the
concept of a call level
so very often when you say Python and
function in Python then you meet don't
meet function you mean callable
so I can call some to sum something up
or I can call Int to
turn a string into end
so
there are different types if you look at
the type of sum
this is a built is a function if you
look a type of int that's a type of int
it's a Class A type the type is type
it's a class so it's a class so here
actually if I say I call I call this
function index wrong
in my beginner courses I often say I
call the function it's not totally
correct but it's good enough because int
is a callable not a function so you can
always check if something is callable by
checking callable
callable and a sum is also callable yeah
they are both callable so you can always
use these
column built in to see if something's
called but means you can write a normal
parentheses so if I say parentheses
square brackets and curly verses so if
you can use a normal parentheses here to
make it do something
in this case it calls new and in it and
all kind of stuff in the background but
you don't care you just use the
parentheses you get something back
and if it's a type of a function or type
of a class doesn't matter that's a basic
principle python very often the type of
object doesn't really matter the
protocol the behavior matters what the
function can do but actually it's it's
very often not so important now what's
the question about typing we don't cover
typing here but typing goes to the
direction just waveform types more to
protocols mobile the behavior this is
iterable is this
whatever it can do is equivalent and so
on
good now we can also make a class call a
bullet that could be interesting so I
make a a class and I call it a call
counter
and then I have an init
I have it in it
and myself and I just set my counter to
have a count and I set it to zero this
would be the first thing I do and then I
do have
a download call so we Define a special
method call so now we have to know what
what it's doing and I have self
here and I just increment it so here you
could hand in a function or do something
more useful the only thing now it's what
I'm doing I'm increment my count so to
make it a
that's usually a good tip to make the
example as simple as possible but still
shows to think so for some reason it
doesn't remove the white space here but
yeah just
think so I have my core counter now make
instance
instance and now if I look at the count
is
zero now I can use parentheses and call
the thing
and this does nothing but now the count
incremented and you see the count is
incremented
now this instance is also callable
not only functions and classes are
callable this instance is also called
because it has this number call so call
level essentially checks for the dunder
call so if you look at this now it's
callable
and now we have a function with a state
so to speak
that kind of violates it if you do
functional programming you might get
some Goose Bumps now a function program
we don't have States so but sometimes
you want it and here now you can make an
object callable and it can hold a state
yeah so call levels could be useful I
think there's also the term functor
flying around that on the other fancy
terms as kind of a similar thing now we
could rewrite we could rewrite our
decorated function as a class as a
parameter white one so we need from
from func tools
import wraps so we need our reps again
so I think maybe we have done up there
but it doesn't matter now we have a
class say so here I capitalize this
might be
you might even run the right to the
lower case typically cluster over
example case but when you use the
decorator you might consider writing a
lowercase seeing lowercase classes
sometimes it makes sense but I save as a
uppercase version here to show that it's
a class
um and now I use my init myself
and I have my text which is part my
parameter and I have to store my text
and of course I use self.text so
instance variable and in it has to have
two underscores and then we have our
download call and the standard call is
essentially
um this thing up here so I can go and
get my this internals here
yeah I can take my internals
and move them here so make it a little
bit more so I done the call yeah so
double underscores usually called
Thunder self function I have to give the
function in here and then
I do something like this so I have to
can get rid of this one and I can just
on those course whatever name I use it
doesn't really matter I can just use a
say here because it's it doesn't do
anything so this will be the same
print and of course now I have to say
self.txt
yeah so that might be some other copy
paste problem here but that's
essentially it and now I should be able
to use it in the same way and I could
use decorator say
um
hello yeah add my ADD function which I
defined now the 21st time at a and b
yeah yeah thanks yeah so I I talked
about it but I didn't type it
thanks
hello yeah so
the proof this is the same thing as this
triple nested function thing
but maybe easier to understand so if you
work with closet regularly you might
prefer this because you can also add
other methods and do more in here
yeah
more the you can write the class this is
a decorator and the
a context manager and an iterator at the
same time if you wanted to I don't know
if you want but it's possible you could
find someone's doing this the size and
decorators can also be used as context
managers typically
yeah very often some of them
and then you can use everything you know
about classes and just have this caller
you have this callable and it might be a
bit more organized you still have the
same number same nesting level but the
class somehow doesn't feel like that
deep yeah
same thing you have a callable and if
it's getting more complex you could use
other methods and this call could call
other methods so just you don't have so
long a function you can always use a
function called other functions but here
you have everything together in the
class more organized so
different ways to achieve the same thing
if you do your right classes regularly
you might prefer this one because you
might be used to it and have some other
ideas to do here
good
yeah
so just look there by online 24 there
the the greatest express training and
instance of the cloud s yeah and then
decorating it using yeah so right
but what's the answer to this question
always go back to this approach
yeah so this makes makes it more makes
it clearer so if I say add equals so
same thing with our set so just that's
what happens so it it makes an instance
and then calls the instance with ad so
first the instance this is in it and
then this is this call calls this call
and hence a function there it is
possible to reuse the same instance to
decorate multiple functions with the
same instance
no you make a new instance for each
class I'm using the class here this is
this is the class I make
and then decorate using that you could
but I'm not sure if this is the effect
you want
because
then it depends that you could if you
want to use this if for this one
everybody will get the same text you
could you can do this so this would be
possible so for this one for this
special case it would be possible uh if
if you want this effect so I could uh
do this yeah
so this should work and now I should be
able to uh I don't have to instantiate
it all the time and and I can do
something like this so it depends on
your use case but it should be possible
if it makes sense depends if you want
them to share things potentially because
they have one instant scenario other
functions could share something over the
self if you if you wanted to that should
should broke yeah
so now
I would roll yeah so now I could use it
again but you have to be careful if this
you're not supposed to but you cannot
prevent it from changing self that
something is always possible it's not
good style I wouldn't expect it but who
knows then
these functions could communicate over
the thing probably not a good idea
yeah another question
this one
see I'm probably I didn't get this
question but this one is exactly if you
unroll this this ad thing and put it in
a function you see there's multiple
function calls
I'm not sure if I understood the
question
yeah this this syntax with ad is you can
only use it in front of a Dev otherwise
you get a syntax that are pretty sure so
this this this death this has to be a
callable and then it has to be directly
in front of a deaf yeah so and this is
also now something you this one I call
this function at
import time so in this case when I
execute a cell we translate to impact if
we put it in a module input device I do
something at import time
so this is some kind of a you can take
over a little bit of the role of a
compiler if you want this decorators
yeah so
not exactly of but you can do tasks that
YouTube compiler you can check things
yeah so compiler check types and so on
you could do similar things here with
The Decorator if it's possible not
always but most of them
you mean as a as an argument here
yeah that's the next next topic you can
decorate classes yeah
yeah you can in a deaf and in the
classes would be a class decorator for
function decorators in front yeah you
correct it's the next topic class
decorations yeah so
[Music]
um
good
I'll show you a few use cases again to
give you some uh an idea on that we go
to class decorations which you I always
would like
to cover so use cases the first use case
would be argument tracking so
it's something you can do now we have
typing typings and other tools that
check for typings but maybe you want to
do something more and if just for the
fun of it you could do a something like
this just as an example Arc check and
you can check out the argument so here I
checked just for the types but you could
check for anything
so you could check for a number that's
between 0 and 100 or whatever you like
that's up to you yeah so I use my func
tools and I use a three level approach
check check yeah and here I use a star
so I make the number of required
arguments optional this we'll see the
second what it means the rest is our
scaffolding our boilerplate yeah Dev
return and here I have I have to make it
maybe a little bit smaller to fit it on
the screen yeah so
um I checked for two things so these Arc
Types on the arguments I desire to have
the types and these are the arguments I
get we will see you later on and if
they're num if they're not they have the
same number I do raise an exception and
say uh you have a type error with this
methods that they don't match in terms
of links and then I go through all of
them so with SIP I can zip together all
the arguments and the types I desire to
have
in lockstep go to some and if if this
argument is not an instance so in Python
very rarely you want to check this type
most of the time you want to check this
is instance
because then you also would check for
the parents of something yeah that's
there might be cases where you want to
use type but if you don't know start
with this instance this is more General
it makes your problem more General and
it typically works better on python yeah
so
don't take everything as absolute there
are always exceptions sometimes you want
type
but if you don't know start with this
instance if it doesn't work consider
type
so and if it's if it's not the right
type I'll throw an exception say I don't
like this yeah so now I could
use my decorator and now I can say Arc
check it's called check checked
checked check yeah and I'd have defined
I guess and I have to Define
two types let's say I want to have
floats now and now I could
reduce it to floats so this um
you could also put your own classes in
there no problem and I have
um two arguments return a plus b
so maybe I should write a macro to put
this in so as I add three and four uh
now it doesn't work yeah it doesn't work
if I added a DOT then it's happy and
because now it floats and it does what
it does so
you might not want to use it in
production but instead of having float
you could also write a function that you
call that is checking something
so you could write your own function
that you put in and then it's checking
for some kind of thing yeah so a string
with a length of five I'm not sure if
you can do this typing
so you're length of five that doesn't
have an underscore on it it wouldn't
work with typing yeah so but you could
write any kind of uh function instead of
just an example maybe I need to update
this a bit make a new thing one make a
check check for something else but you
might get a idea what you can do with it
so the thing is you can use this pretty
long track and then when you apply it it
turns boils down to this short
application
that's the whole thing and you can use
it again and again and again
yeah that's that's otherwise you can
always do it uh directly good the next
example is a bit different
a bit different in terms of what it's
doing and it's called registering so I
can register something so if they have a
registry which is not the Windows
registry but it's just an example of
something very I want to put something
which I can find back later
there might be quite a few use cases for
the things so you can put something that
you can find find back later and I use a
dictionary for this time I don't put it
into the function I put it in the global
namespace on the module now my notebook
is the same as a file
and I have this three level thing
because I want to name this different
kind of things with the name we'll see
what it means in a second function my
functional reps and here say registry
and this is a dictionary and I use that
default
so 34th is just a trick so set default
is going into the dictionary looking for
the name it finds the name it will
retrace the object and then append this
object
if it doesn't it puts in a new list in
retrieves to new list and I can append
it so I don't have to say okay if this
is empty put in a list with one element
and the next time append is a list I can
do this in one line this is nothing
specific as it's just dictionary work
so if you want I can take this apart
this is like three things at once here
okay but this is just appending to the
list and then I do my regular thing so
now I have two different ones I have
registered at call and I do have
register at def so if you look there at
call first so let's let's do the
register at at call so I use my
register at call First and I give it a
name
to have a category
and I Define my function
A and B and I return a plus b
returns a bit slow here A plus b
yeah so and
perform actually we look at the registry
before I execute it I look at the
registry and the registry is an empty
dictionary so I can inspect Global
variables here so step by step which is
nice in the notebook and if I look at
the registry now you see the registry is
still empty but now if I call my
function
and I look at my registry again now I
have I know that my function had been
called and if I call my function again
doesn't matter what arguments I use then
if I look at my registry my
uh function has been just at the same
function so again the list gets longer
so it's not particularly useful but you
see something happens and you can of
course Implement whatever you like so
every time the function is called I
noticed this in my registry
and maybe we need some kind of plug-in
system or something so somebody supplies
a function somewhere and then it ends up
in a registry or something like this
good so now how to clean my registry
very easy registry is a dictionary so
and I'll say clear and it clears a
dictionary registry and everything is
out again yeah so
and now I do the same thing but I'll say
registry at death
so
I'm lazy at definition yeah and now I
say complex or something
complex and now I look at my registry
and now
something different now when I Define
the function it will end up in my
registry that might maybe the more
useful use case for this one and if I
call my function
if I call my function nothing changes in
the registry because when I call it
nothing
it's different yeah so
whenever somebody is using your
decorator and defines a function it will
end up in a deck in the dictionary so
you can kind of collect functions
somebody else defines for what purpose
ever yeah so and you see now it's a bit
different so it's it's two level and see
here I return the function
here nothing so I don't replace original
functions I don't need reps here because
I don't do anything I'll return the
function unchanged but before I return
it I know that I had somebody defined it
that's why the registry
yeah so this is a use case where I
mentioned this happens at import time so
if I import my module there's a
decorator this will be executed and I
know somebody some module imported
somebody uh defined a function that's
supposed to be somewhere when there's
supposed to be some to do something with
it yeah
the reason
yeah I saw the budget but do you but you
have to import from collections to full
thick you can do the same thing this is
easy enough here that's why I don't have
to introduce another data structure but
would we do the same thing the the
voltage can do a bit more even
uh than this one yeah but you're right
collection module has a defaulting which
is the this one you just have to specify
that it's supposed to be listed in the
first thing and then it would do it yeah
but this would mean import and then you
have to initialize it two more lines and
let's say okay oh that's argument good
okay this would be the example for
registration which is a bit different
and you can solve a kind of different
problem what
you wouldn't have so
these are function decorators starting
from two to six I think if I'm not
mistaken if you have class decorators
good messages class decorators are a bit
simpler than function decorations and
they are useful and class decorators can
take over quite a few things where in
the past used meta classes anybody use
the meta class
build it so a lot of things you you you
did with meta classes you can do
class decorators not everything there
are few things you still need meta class
but very few and I never found a use
case for these things too in any
production thing so it's not that common
obviously and also the answer class
method which is new which makes it
easier because we will see
class decorators you can inherit you
have to apply them you know all the
child the children don't get it so let's
look at class decorators
which we mentioned already class
decorators so that's a class decorator
so I just write a function
whatever does it takes a class and the
most important thing it has to return
this class
so now you're totally free to do
whatever you want so this is a the
boilerplate you want
and now you do whatever you like with
the cross and you could
I modify it but you can also just
inspect it which might be the more
useful case yeah now I say okay class
dot uh
you new attribute or something yeah you
attribute something now I use this
decorator and now you're correct you can
use a
um
decorator
no
decorate or syntax here and I can say
Mark and I can mark my class
Class A yeah and I don't put anything in
there and use pass yeah and if you look
at the cost now you see it does have the
attribute new attribute
so this does exactly the same so this is
not very difficult so this one is doing
this
yeah so it gets a Class A
oh
and puts in the class
and this is exactly the same with the
decorator is doing but again you don't
have to a class definition can be pretty
long here if they look at the very
bottom of your class after 50 lines or
100 lines 150 lines
see that this class is modified you can
make it very visible on top that this
class was modified that's essentially
what happens
yeah
much easier no nested function
definitions just get the cost and return
the class and do something with the
clause in this case I add something
that
maybe maybe not good idea but you can
also inspect the class and do something
with the class
and for this I have a use case
foreign
the name of the file but I can always
check method name check
load
method name check so
this is something this is a little bit
more involved class decorator actually
this comes from my tutorial about
metaclasses usually with meta classes
first but you can use with a class
decorator so the thing is I would like
to inspect all the methods of the class
and if they are more than 30 characters
I don't like them
yeah you see you can change the max
length here I put some talk strings in
here and these are my things and now I
get my class and now it's a bit more
evolved I Define
there's a decorator
here and since I need to have two levels
because I give it a parameter same thing
as before yeah this is a parameterized
one so I give the parameter after 30. I
get my Class here and I go to the dict
of the class so the dictator for class
contains all that repeats
as a dictionary with items I get the key
in the value which I call name and
object which is more called useful names
here then if it's callable if it's a
method
then
I check if the length of the name is
more than my specified 30 characters or
whatever I specify I don't like it and I
generate error message which I put
together here as with the F string say
okay this is here that's what I wanted
you but you cannot have names longer
than this and this okay so let's apply
it first we can look at the source code
in a second so as I
go in here and say check
name links and I Define
my
class class B yeah
with a method which is fine
method self
not itself
so when you talk and type as itself does
nothing pass or
Def
method
with
uh
very
long
name
that
is
not nice so so I don't know some other
people do this I don't do this one so
okay
okay now do this when you see yeah I've
I made a syntax I forgot the the column
but when you put the colon and you do
this
uh
yeah why doesn't work you should give me
an error message
yeah the parameter so I have to put the
parentheses there to make it work so
that's also a way to make it without
them with parenthesis and now I kind of
do this it doesn't like it and give me
the error message say okay this name has
43 characters only 30 a lab yeah
so this could be useful yeah so you
could apply
Nuki check
and this one doesn't even import so
there's no way to start your program
if somebody of course if somebody just
comments how to decorate or it works but
this and so yeah that's that's kind of
way and now you could also think okay
since I go over the callables now I
could say please decorate all methods
with this decorator so like as an
argument I give in The Decorator and
then I have this one going over all
these callable objects these are the
methods and put the decorator on this is
syntax replace it in the dictionary
maybe maybe not to use a set attribute
might be imported yeah set attribute is
pretty much the same thing as replacing
a dictionary but there are a few things
that don't go to the dictionary like
properties and so you have to be careful
this one you have to figure out what
works for you but this would be possible
so if you have a class with 20 methods
you want to decorate all of them you
write your own class decorator and they
say okay please decorate all these
messages decorator
maybe that's a different a different
approach doing this but it would work it
would work
good
actually I found another example here
yeah this is temperature check but it's
that's fine good
class decorators are conceptually much
more simple than
a function decorators but nevertheless
can be useful
good we still have 10 minutes and
they're pretty much true yeah questions
decorators especially parameterized
decorators
in a lovely fashion
yeah in the end it's just functions it
returns something
I don't think we need any special
testing method for this so you you have
it's a function that returns a new
function
so I don't see anything
particularly different than testing
other functions
so maybe we need to make a use case for
this we always say okay this is a
decorate on how do I test this decorator
y
[Music]
levels right yeah yeah
like how for example would you
approach testing like the second level
dedicatedly ignoring
the other two levels and
yeah that's not that easy I think
because you have syntaxby put it inside
you cannot just write it outside and
then inject it in there to otherwise you
could like have this this inner function
as tested by itself and then just give
it a parameter to put it in
I'm not sure if this is possible because
it's this the scoping thing
that would probably mean to use a water
or something that I don't wanna do this
I'm not sure if it's possible I have to
have to have to check but the whole
thing is one thing so probably what I
would like to do I just write the
scaffolding and then this one calls a
function that doesn't work and you test
this function it doesn't work
because this one you only you only need
a scaffolding you only need the Steph
Dev and then
inside whatever you do you call other
function that does a real work when you
give it the parameters and get the
result back and you do the more
complicated stuff in a separate function
that doesn't doesn't work and not
directly in the decorator
and then you could trace this function
separately that might be the most
sensible approach just the white and
Conquer yeah
question
yeah
I don't know what you mean use two
decorators in innermost thing
so this is three level this checklist is
reliable one yeah
work
okay
you can you can decorate The Decorator
probably yeah so uh for this one I I
cannot say yes I have to have to test it
out because this
it's like chess you can only think so
many moves that kind of but the problem
would work
this one is decorating in here and
inside in the front that's totally fine
yeah probably you could do this so but
again this if you take this guts out
here yeah and right put it in our own
function that's what you want to do in
this one you want to test write in your
own function in a helper function that
you can test separately and they just
call the function here and hand in this
arcs there's only dogs in the in the you
just have to make sure this to reference
these guys to put them in the closure
otherwise it wouldn't be there yeah so
but it's maybe the easiest
there's an online question
I haven't used it for error handling I
use exceptions I'm not sure but how you
can use error handling
so that might be use case I'm not aware
of a use case I don't remember seeing
one
I haven't used a photo handling so I
have no experience with them potentially
possible but I don't know what how
exactly so
I don't think so but I don't know I
haven't tested it but it just seems like
the same amount of work but I I wouldn't
I would need to test it so I don't know
so
but it seems like the number of calls is
the same so it shouldn't be a big
difference
sometimes yeah
class decorators are for classes not for
instances
yeah you can as you can use it we have
five minutes left so you can always so
be this one would always happen at
definition time but if you use this one
this one you can do any time later on
your code
and you don't have to do this you can
always make a new class with a new name
so you could always instead of this you
call this
so we keep the old one and just give it
the new name yeah but if the class you
would do something like this
that's totally possible and this one you
can do anytime in your code
that would be possible
do you need a decorative okay if you
don't mind implement it in the class but
you
yeah actually perhaps something I do
have a meta class tutorial where I just
replace
there's a function called generate um
make do you want the classes or the
instances
the instances then you can implement it
in the class I think we don't even need
decorate us with you just have a base
class inherit and then you use it in it
and the inner just counting how many
time it's very difficult about the thing
because you might create new references
and this one gets deleted somewhere you
keep the referencer right you might want
to use a weak reference stick for this
which is not that easy
so these kind of meta things can you
might generate some Phantom effects you
don't want to assist
[Music]
performance traps when using decorators
to extensive
it's function quotes So function calls
are pretty expensive from python
compared to other languages for sure and
you always add a bunch of function calls
so it could it could impact performance
it depends how often the attacker writer
is called so my register one is called
only once usually doesn't matter because
it happens in import time which is
expensive anyways you wouldn't see a
difference but if you're called the
function that's decorated that goes
through all this Jazz to find it
millions of times in your code you
probably see a difference especially if
the rest of the function doesn't do much
if the functions does it does a lot then
this extra overhead it's present
supervised very small but if the
function is just doing one plus one like
here then The Decorator takes way more
time than our a plus b in our case yeah
it could have an effect but again this
depends very much in use case
another question do you have many more
use cases for decorating
cases
so in general everything you you that
has nothing to do with your specific
domain language you want to reuse in one
way or the other and the objectively you
could use inheritance but then you
always have apparent clause and
everything is inherent from this class
this would be one way of doing it and
with decorators you can get anything
that's cross-cutting concern so and that
probably you can come up with something
and say okay I programmed this and I
program pretty much the same thing in
your program pretty much I think three
projects are totally different but I do
a very similar thing the logging the
timing profiling these are kind of these
uh cross-cutting concerns that can be
useful and seism and Mumbai use it to
specify data types because they compile
to other languages so if you want to go
out so if you access a database you
might I don't know
give the column data types with a
decorator or something I'm not sure if
this could be use case
so
not not everything that's possible is
the best solution that might be easier
solution yeah so I don't want to sell
your decorators it's one tool in your
tool chest you can use that might be
easier Solutions but for the fun you can
try and decorate
good I think we are out of time
another question
yeah you have to you have to check here
it's not optional you have to recheck
the ins how I am called These are meta
programming as you have to check is and
I'm called as a pyramid or not and and
do I want to take the from the three go
from the three level to the two level
version it's possible but I haven't put
in here that's it's a meta programming I
couldn't do it right now I have to look
it up but there's some stack Overflow
questions about it pretty sure
yeah yes you have to check if I'm if I'm
called with the parameter of this out or
if I'm used with other parentheses I
just kind of add empty parentheses to it
virtually have something like this
good so thank you very much so if you if
you would like to have more teaching I
have some flyers here if you want more
python things I do this for a living so
if you want me I can come and teach you
more otherwise thank you very much and I
wish you a good lunch
[Applause]